[Musica]
ai ragazzi siamo crew mente e c'è anche
la possibilità che ci sia un giullare
cioè quello che deve fare finta di farsi
ammazzare e voi avete ci potrebbero
essere delle persone che vogliono farsi
assolutamente ammazzare anche in che
senso
nel senso che tu in questa modalità
oltre ad avere la mappa specchiata che
già non si capisce una sega ci sono
persone anzi una una sola che
l'obiettivo è farsi uccidere se qualcuno
lo ammazza la partita finisce il gesto
siano non lo sapeva mai fatta st
modalità sono un po arretrato sulle
nuove modalità mondate vi amo il gas
però è sempre bello scoprirle mi sento
un vecchio che tenta di giocare
videogioco di art and chic che fa o due
che è morto alcuno ai bagagli che
abbiamo già il nostro primo impostore
giornico punto è impossibile magari
impossibile cosa succede qui cosa vedo
me ne vado e basta va bene non ho capito
niente di quello che ho visto però due
che stanno vicino a un corpo non fra
capello
andiamo avanti ragazzi allora è una
situazione abbastanza problematica vista
così però di sicuro non posso non ho
capito cosa sta succedendo credo che che
noia sia al già state da che ripassa
l'attivo di la ragazzina che la cosa
veramente salles vediamo
[Musica]
cos'è qualcosa abbiamo stiamo facendo
siamo tutti simulati lasciando qui
anch'io sono la caccia bellis queste
sono le cose che gli piace lo chiamo gas
nessuno fa una mazza di niente tutti
disinteressati totalmente che poi
l'unico l'unico che l'aveva ucciso non
era tra di novi ligure perché se ammazzi
qualcuno difficile che ci stai vicino
una bellissima come cosa tratto dati non
si sono neanche accorti che stiamo
facendo tutto ciò ma secondo me march
raga march perché l'amico che non era lì
sicuro non erano in nessuno di loro è
figlia della casta cosa vediamo se ci
sono altri corpi in giro se no va bene
così io ho finito le mie tasche non so
gli altri a quanto stanno ma porca vacca
sete lenti come la morte o c'è roba che
ti prego per yara
ma dov'erano in giappone scusa ma
veramente e non mi aveva visto ma cavolo
cui è possibile oggi ci sono passato
adesso è una x in joint vero ma sul
serio non fermarci perché credo che sia
facile ma ce ne se mi votate sapete che
qui trova partito mi spiego non diciamo
che c'è stata una riunione è durata
molto tempo tutti noi quattro vedere a
caso molto naso avanti a caso io mi
sento votato è vero che puo essere anche
morto esatto
e no sei morto ok ma solo al mattino non
succede niente
ovviamente il pagliaccio può autovotarsi
anche a potrebbe essere anche vessicchio
il pagliaccio sarà giocata benissimo
non lo so ragazzi conviene fare meeting
perché tanto non lo buttiamo fuori sono
quindi ho finito le tasche meeting
vincitore ma no niente mi piace il
gelato non esercitiamo dai fa testé
missioni quante ne ha fatte che poi ci
vado in giro non vale se perdiamo così
non si impegnano a una donna quanto è
stato tanto il dio è orribile due ore
che assembramenti allora cos'è sta roba
qua per secchio stanley che fa le tasche
che l'ha finita intanto sta a fare
shields certo cosa finito di tusk che
sta a fare sci maledetto che noia ma la
vide me l'ha ucciso davanti no no no
favi
io lo penso di non poter neanche io
posso anche di non dire niente penso che
tu c'eri vi possa arrivare alla samp
parti sei una cattiva impostrip l'ha
ucciso davanti a noi ma abbiamo portato
già tutti basta basta basta storie basta
mi dispiace vessicchio per la call di
prima mi fa che poi sono pari a un
casino
allora allora squadra attimo ascoltata
questo ragionamento se tu noi voti me
quindi siamo 2 2 poi abbiamo perso se
sei più meta abbiamo perso comunque
perché perché noi favorevole secondi che
noia è decennio e non è imposto nei ma
ti assicuro che impostore e voglio
ancora centro del ragionamento stai
facendo e skipass chi parla ok poi
scappare
ma che abbiamo perso mannaggia devo
provare a dribblare il tavolo non
provare a dribblare il tavolo schalke
aspetta niente perso la mamma ciao non è
festa non le pensa non è fessa ero io mi
sono ammazzato da solo ma che partita
macché ma cosa allora il discorso è che
siamo partiti che marcino l'aversa gli
può stare ma non è impostore mi ha fatto
troppo ridere questa cosa perché possono
io per una volta mi scusai ma allora
baathista destra che noi a rob
tutto il resto è un casino vero aiuto
aiuto sabotiamo meno male che la mappa è
dritta stavolta non famo casini
salutiamo
elettrica ok non posso ammazzare nico
punto perché se non un casino che è
difficile perché non si può fare la
prima chi la prima era molto importante
che noi è stata prima si chiama perché
noi a ok vento voglio rimanere nelle
feste ho paura che la gente mi trovi
perché non avete chiuso are chiusa la
porta
adesso esco va bene vado vediamo adesso
le porto che noia ok e proprio io che
noi in via del tutto normale ea sinistra
cioè l'area
no quella dove c'è il memory come
cacchio si chiama dobbiamo per farlo a
dare un voto abbiamo detto voi votate un
bene dobbiamo fare un'altra kinsey siamo
in otto ragazzi perché deve esserci
dovrebbe esserci accorgesse ha
storicamente che non c'è
allora io aspetta vado avanti di jack
calmina riletto fa troppo ridere
basta fare una doppia raga basta fare
una doppia ed è fatta nascita pare la
doppia dato da bambini se c'è ancora da
solo se ancora da solo possa provare a
ucciderlo ok mattino nei dibatti l'ho
visto passare prima no niente prima
vista fascino che partivo insomma
partitona incredibile
[Musica]